خوف على دمعه ام وليس على حياه لا تزال في
بدايتها فكلمات المتظاهر محمد مهدي كرمي
القليله التي وصلت لعائلته قبل اعدامه
شنقا كانت موجهه لابيه عقوبته هي الاعدامه
لا تخبر امي
التهمه ولو كانت بلا مسوغ قانوني او بدون
حضور محامنه باتت حاضره وتساق لكل متظاهر
معتقل التعرض للحرس الثوري وقوات الباسيج
المرتبطه به بات احدت بهاته اما العقوبه
الفوريه فهي الاعدام
ومن الاعتقال للاعدام طريق لا محطه وقوف
او استراحه فيه قد يمر ببعض المحاكمات
الصوريه الخجوله التي لا ترقى للمعايير
الدوليه محمد مهدي كرمي ومحمد حسيني وهما
في العشرينات من العمر اعدم شنقا بتهمه
قتل عنصر امن اثناء الاحتجاجاته ليرتفع
بذلك عدد عمليات الاعدام المنفذه الى
اربعه فيما 10 اشخاص اخرين بانتظاره تنفيذ
العقوبه
الالاف غيرهم يقبعون خلف ابواب السجون
ومنها تتسرب رواياتنا وادله عن عمليه
تعذيب لانتزاع الاعترافات المطلوبه فقوه
النظام الاساسيه المتمثله بالحرس الثوري
والمحاطه بهاله القوه الجباره سقط قناعها
امام محتاجين اختاروا لمواجهه رغم القمع
والتخويف هذا الضعف ورده مراقبون لصراع
داخليا بين اجنحه السلطه المنقسمه بشان
التعامل مع ملفات عده وبمقدمتها
الاحتجاجات في ما وصفها اخرون بتكتيكا
ينتهجه النظام كل فتره اي السماحه بخروج
مظاهرات كل حين بهدف تشويها واتهام
المتظاهرين بممارسه العنف المسلح
لتبقى الروايه الابرز ان القبضه الحديديه
الامنيه للنظام مجرد نمر من ورق تروج له
اله دعائيه رسميه ضخمه